tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su
the sims quattro ragazzi che che cazzo
sta facendo quel che ogni volta che la
pro mi ricordo che un gioco serio
soprattutto la sua cosa è fantastico è
la madonna questo stupro che regga nello
scorso episodio avevo chiesto di
iscrivermi in modo per uccidere un
simbolicamente ragazzi quest'episodio
voglio tentare di ucciderlo di ucciderne
uno almeno se riesco perché è il mio
intento perché sono una brava persona
quindi la cosa che mi viene in mente da
fare ovviamente fare una carneficina
comunque volevo dirvi ragazzi che non è
così facile perché mi avete scritto
costruisci una piscina riempila d'acqua
e poi fargli affogare dentro ragazzi le
piscine in the scenes 4 non ci sono
quindi non posso fare sta cosa che voi
ci a trovare un altro modo adesso
vediamo che cazzo sta facendo intanto
quello dorme sul divano fratelli schleck
dorme sul letto qui ci sono dei
maccheroni al formaggio avariati giusto
per prima cosa devono iniziare a
mangiare una porzione di cibo avariato
almeno ha creato nel cesso l'ultima
volta hulk sentite ma vabbè questo
schifo seriamente lo sta facendo si sta
mangiando del cibo avariato allora
vediamo se così è scolato ucciderlo
anche se ne dubito non me ne frega una
sega se puzzo tutto lo magno lo stesso
mariah bellissima fatto una faccia
strappa ancora nonostante ragazzi faccia
schifo lui continuava la gente è più
stupida di così non può essere che
voglio capire chi ha pagato nel cesso
perché fa veramente schifo alla ragazzi
di reni aspettare domani mattina e mi
sembra giornata ottima per uccidere una
persona che non è in dolce a te cosa che
una incinta ho il terrore di sapere che
cosa tira fuori l'europa va bene sono le
4 di notte
cosa pulisci piatti alle 4 di notte
hanno sei talmente grasso i piatti più
entrano nello stomaco shayk mi sembra
giusto era fatto l'ultima volta
gustavano perché non ricordo eccolo trek
che arriva in tutta la sua mascolinità
ragazzi
sono una persona perfida ragazzi però
devo farlo allora mentre dorme vediamo
cosa posso che citare per ammazzarla
ragazzi alla quale abbiamo il catalogo
di morte cessi bagni letto poltrone cose
così compro questo tappeto bello
fantastico lavoro sto tappeto sarà una
macchina mortale sono convinto
trasferisci unità familiare perfetto
ragazzino perché voglio cioè vorrei tipo
prendermi una villa della madonna prima
di ucciderli giusta per avere sto sfizio
quando a brava fiora che ti metti a
pulire cagate di hulk fantastico e shrek
tornerà dal lavoro eccolo perfetto
chiama che ci trasferiamo che è meglio
che sta a casa mio già rotto le balle
perfetto allora ragazzi la dimora
perdono per morire dovrebbe essere tipo
fantastica ho paura di vedere cediamo
madonna che estero la villa del secolo
ragazzi perfetto la nuova casa sarà una
cosa epica anche perché prima stavamo in
un buco rio verde c'è anche una ciotola
del cane qua fantastico rai un pisolino
no hanno dato non dormi devi mori allora
che sarà e la villa della morte la
chiamiamo così no perché devono morire
qua dentro un piano di sopra per la
madonna cos'è sta roba
e adesso arrivato all'ora di morire
ragazzino te che fai lo zombie perché
tanto ti ammazzo uguali si sa i sali
pure le scale con la tua video di tacere
perfetto ci siamo allora vediamo se
riesco a trovare qualcosa di decente per
ucciderli verni un labirinto sei serio è
fidata della madonna nov adesso cosa sto
cose troppo figo rega alla ragazzi
propongo di fare una cosa bellissimi
facciali ammazzo tutti e tre insieme
prova in un modo diverso sono troppo
malvagio la prima persona che ammazzò e
gustavo che gustava da vieni qua nuovi
il culo subito alla ragazzina prima cosa
questa funziona per forza perché mi
avete consigliata stavi facendo i
compiti non si fanno i compiti puntato
libro voglio provare ad ammazzarlo la
mia mente non sia tra ragazzi di
ammazzarsi murando lo vivo e la cosa mi
piace questa è la prima morte ragazzi
gustavo finisce così mi dispiace allora
strumento muro fantastico sei pronto a
morire gustavo eccola lì perfetto murato
vivo ci siamo da ragazzino se funziona
perché è un esperimento e non funziona
vediamo perfetto ordine ai fantastico 6
esiliato all'interno di quattro mura è
l'unica cosa che puoi fare sono i
compiti sono messo ragazzo muore prima
del previsto amo questa
cosa e ogni andare avanti veloce vista
mi fermo però non può fare un cazzo
al telefono anche non prende il telefono
là dentro c'è tra ecco infatti non c'e
linea morirà da solo prima o poi nel
frattempo vediamo che cosa combinare
agli altri ma va bene basta che cazzo
sono così corrono friaca cui si
permettono che questa è la madonna che
ignora chaleco ovviamente dorme mi
sembrava strano che non lo facesse
quindi ragazzi ratchet oca strech
purtroppo mi dispiace l'arin anzio dove
rialzati perché non mi piace che stai
dormendo zio devi fare cose più
produttive si può camminare per la
camera con questo sexy vestitino che ti
ritrovi una roba tipo che metto un noto
ho trovato ragazzi basta dove la nostra
da bagno e qua fa il bagno col non
onorano con la schiuma parlo con la
schiuma al bagno e sono non va bene
costruisco un muro ecco perfetto ok lo
caccia finito è sparito shrek a caso
come cazzo fai esser lì fuori e ben
tanto in tanto gustavo si sta divertendo
vedo cosa fare il tagliere riuscissimo a
taglianti le mani
lo sapevo e non è morto è morto cazzo a
ragazzi celo celo leather questa faccio
bene fino alla morte fiona finché non si
piscia addosso e poi si va prendi il
succo di frutta quello buono
perfetta la faccio tipo bere un bordello
finché non si piscia donna la madonna
con due vince neanche uno avevo due alla
volta fantastico e la faccio pisciano
addosso e le metto un televisore sopra
la pipì e in questo modo dovrebbe in
teoria re nella scossa credo andava a
far bere tutti quanti ma non c'è verso
no dove vai
no no no no no no non ti picchio c'è
soltanto provato ad andare al cesso anzi
per sicurezza tolgo tutti i cessi della
casa li tolgo cioè o vanno a pisciare a
casa degli altri o nulla non la fanno da
nessuna parte perché non possono
eccolo qua perfetto per adesso vi sfido
io ad andare in bagno
la vedo dura ragazzi però stavolta live
ai file fatto addosso fatta addosso deve
proprio andare in bagno me ne frega un
cazzo da fi addosso veloce veloce doveva
doveva la camminata sexy doveva
[Musica]
stronzo dimenticato un cesso nel porsi
come cazzo hai tirato fuori sto cesso ma
no dai dovete morire bravissimi
bravissimi mezz'ora mezz'ora per sta
merda
adesso che siamo arrivati a questo punto
ragazzi perciò messo mezz'ora di
riuscire a trovare un qualcosa di
elettrico in modo da dovrebbe dare un
forno a microonde credo c'è una roba che
cos'è stato o di televisore per bambini
pinguino visione lo voglio subito un
televisore è come se questo questo
questo è l'ora della verità ce la
possiamo fare accende e ci sto provando
ragazzi però non secondo me non funziona
[ __ ] shrek devi morire ce la fai
aspetta a spegnere accenni un po di
volte così almeno niente non funzionano
che è successo che cazzo è successo che
staimo ragazzi mi è morta fiona rob riti
figlia mia vorno da cucina a legna o e
la madonna questo è fatto apposta per
dar fuoco a tutto in qualche modo le
tende dovranno prendere fuoco
maledizione qualcosa mi prende fuoco
qualcosa ti prego ragazzi li ho moratti
direttamente vi vista stanza allora
qualcosa dovrà succedere se siete in una
stanza piena di fornelli se no non mi
prende fuoco la la tenda che sta sopra
forma impossibile da c'è ma poi mi
spiegate come fanno un prender fuoco la
tenda è impossibile ha già la pentola
dentro la tenda come cazzo è possibile
che non se riuscissi a dov'è finito
gustavo modo non ho nomi son pernod aimi
che mi sono perso la sua morte ho
aspettato la vita intera e poi mi sono
perso la sua mamma [ __ ] ci siano
ragazzine di osservarli finché non
muoiono e poi passa perché non è
possibile ci sono stato anni anni
attentare mi è morto che cazzo si
abbracciano e sono per morire ora sta
scoppiando di impazienza briko tra il
nuovo fagottino di gioia ma non può
partorire sta morendo kevin anzi entrare
che ora di andare tre ore voglio vedere
che cosa succede ma sono un tocco di un
cazzo 27 26 ragazzi ci siamo ci siamo è
morta al caso 9 se risveglia allora ci
siamo ai ragazzi quanto rieccola ecco
congratulazioni e un maschietto qualcosa
maschietti così stanno per morire nome
alla chiama salvatore salvatore da
patata lo chiamo questi ragazzi perché è
l'unico che si salva ovviamente è
l'unico che rimane vivo gli altri due
muoiono perché sono sta morendo di fame
e tragico veder morire la madre il padre
davanti ai suoi occhi appena nato
proprio
e verde almeno queste perderlo perché
l'altro la blu perfetto ragazzi il
bambino è salvo loro due stanno per di
schiattare mancano sei ore morte per
fame tra trovare ragazzi ci siamo una
cosa non lo so perché non ho ancora
visto come moron sim ci siamo se fuori
fuori fuori
già abbiamo fa chi cazzo me piagni tu
hai pianto più bello della sacco di
ragazzi ficazione questo la morte al
tablet
ok la gioconda ingribelli che cazzo fai
implora perfino no non ci credo
implorare la morte rituale alla morte
per fiom e dai salva la non ci credo
oddio si incazza non fanno che si sta
incalzando mio dio
shrek non ha ucciso non hanno ucciso
fiona mio dio
savo avesse ucciso strech sarebbe stato
tragico presentazione michela sì certo
ti puoi presentare la morte non mi dire
che ti risponde perché potremo che cosa
fa cosa ma poi stringere amicizia con la
morte spettegola non ai break poi
spettegolare con la morna è fantastico
io non ho mai vista una cosa più bella
di questa cioè tu puoi spettegolare che
c'è qui puoi forte lavica proprio
lamentati dai problemi
chiedi della sua giornata il
nervosissimo ok come non detto meglio
lasciar perdere rimane soltanto slack
ragazzi è stata la bellissima avventura
però dispiace è finita in modo tragico
rai maledizione che meglio si è fatto a
cambiarti ma ancora capire come mai
nessuno è entrato a dare un'occhiata
perché si possono chiusi da giorni però
siamo eccolo eccolo
che cazzo fa il ritardo per il lavoro
certo mi sembra giusto andare a lavorare
il suo è morto anche shrek quindi ci
siamo dove la morte dove la morte quando
eccola era tuo amico sa è che non è che
devi fare lo stronzo per forza una deve
fare lo stronzo fine della partita se è
stato fantastico ragazza è stata la cosa
più bella che abbia mai fatto in realtà
la cosa che volevo fare ragazzi e farli
morire ecco tipo così solo che non so
come o farli morire col fuoco che non ci
sono riuscito manco per il bene quindi
far ancora tutto molti ragazzi se
abbiamo fatto in un modo o nell'altro ad
ucciderli tutti direi che possono
chiudere qui il video ragazzi servito è
piaciuto ma sotto al suo commento mi
piace anche occasioni facebook e come
non vi adottata una descrizione anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
trovata nella descrizione svelare city
scrivete di civiltà non prossimo video
belle ragazze